Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Salve. Questa è un'occasione per dare voce
ad alcune esperienze che ho fatto nella mia vita.
Esperienze così diverse che potrei anche parlare di vite diverse.
Sono qui a raccontarvi alcuni sogni che ho realizzato
e che, da idee, sono diventati fatti, fatti concreti.
Questa mia prima vita, che è durata 22 anni, nel sistema bancario,
mi ha vista protagonista in diversi casi di successo,
e ho lavorato nel campo della finanza, tesoreria,
commerciale, marketing - nei settori tradizionali della banca
e poi mi è stato dato un piccolo compito e così ho creato
il primo modello di banca multi-canale virtuale in Italia:
grande successo, questa capacità di creare dei modelli
e degli strumenti di lavoro utili agli impiegati, ai clienti,
mi ha dato la possibilità di guardarmi intorno e ho pensato
di cambiare esperienza rimanendo sempre nel mondo della finanza,
e quindi, dal primo modello di banca virtuale,
ho scelto di vivere quattro anni a Milano in un'esperienza simile,
nel mondo della finanza, ma in un'azienda molto più ampia, più grande,
e ho creato dei modelli, anche lì, di automazione dei processi di conoscenza,
nel SanPaolo IMI e ho creato una piattaforma di knowledge management dove,
in tempo reale, tutte le informazioni arrivavano dalla fabbrica di prodotto
(fondi, gestioni patrimoniali) alle reti delle filiali.
Grande successo, grande iniziativa, abbastanza interessanti,
mi hanno chiesto (perché guadagnavo veramente tanti soldi)
di proseguire la famosa carriera e girare il mondo
per razionalizzare le filiali estere della rete San Paolo IMI
e quindi dovevo andare in giro per i paesi dell'Est, l'Asia,
e rivedere un po' tutto il sistema di offerta delle reti, delle filiali.
Qui è scattata una molla, e ho cominciato a provare del disagio,
in questa mia fine della prima vita. Ho provato disagio perché oggi
è più sotto gli occhi di tutti l'inadeguatezza del sistema bancario, in Italia e nel mondo.
È evidente - abbiamo visto anche i fallimenti delle imprese dovuti,
soprattutto, non all'incapacità, o alla mancanza di creatività degli imprenditori
(ma) spesso perché le banche lasciano sempre il cerino corto al cliente.
Mi sono sentita un po' fuori luogo e qui, diciamo, mi sono persa.
Allora ho cominciato a pensare di poter dare quella mia energia,
quella voglia, quella tenacia, quella voglia di cambiamento,
di metterla in gioco e di proporla in altri modelli.
Allora, sono andata, ho fatto una breve esperienza in Brasile, dove
volevo avere un contatto diretto con la povertà.
Ero molto ricca - una ricchezza fatta di soldi-
e volevo cercare una ricchezza diversa, una ricchezza interiore.
E così ho messo un nuovo paio di occhiali e ho visto la vita in modo differente.
Così ho messo in piedi la mia impresa sociale e quindi, nella seconda vita,
ho fondato "Officina Creativa", lanciando vari progetti
che toccavano vari temi, settori dimenticati:
ho lavorato con i minori a rischio di devianza;
ho lavorato nel campo della comunicazione sociale;
nelle scuole, parlando di energia rinnovabile e di risparmio energetico;
ho sviluppato modelli che potessero dare valore a dei comportamenti intangibili,
che sono quelli della puntualità nel pagamento delle bollette dell'acqua, per esempio;
e ho messo in piedi tante attività lanciando dei brand e dei nuovi modelli di sviluppo.
È nato poi il grande amore con “Made in carcere”,
perché il mio desiderio era quello di incidere in situazioni estremamente disagiate.
“Made in carcere” è un 'esperienza molto interessante, ed è questa la mia seconda vita,
e già ho in mente nel 2013 – credo che partirà senz'altro,
che ci riuscirò – è un'esperienza di una summer school,
perché il mio sogno, da realizzare nella mia vecchiaia, è quello di stare sempre
insieme ai bambini. Quindi creare una casa famiglia, delle summer school,
creare dei modelli "educativi" e formativi
pieni di gioia e di ironia. Tornando alla seconda vita,
il progetto che mi sta prendendo più tempo e che occupa gran parte della mia vita
è questo contatto che ho con il mondo del carcere.
Contatto molto difficile, molto forte come impatto,
però vero, dove l'assenza di qualsiasi elemento genera
il massimo della creatività e sviluppa un senso della creatività,
ma anche della sopravvivenza, molto forte.
Ho cominciato questo progetto di “Made in carcere” pensando
- nel momento in cui ho visto tante buste di carta
che si distruggevano nel giro di poche ore,
due ore, due giorni al massimo, quelle borse tutte patinate, bellissime -
ho pensato che potesse essere utile far cucire
(perché è molto semplice cucire una busta)
e abbiamo pensato di realizzare del package
per fare la spesa, per fare dei regali, ma anche per seminari ed eventi.
Semplicemente, invece di portarmi le borse, porto un'etichetta.
(L'idea è di) stampare l'etichetta dello sponsor (e) attaccarla sulla busta di tessuto.
Questa busta, che ha il marchio, gira, e quindi
va avanti il concetto di diffusione della conoscenza
attraverso questa formula di marketing sociale,
riesce a durare tanto tempo, anche anni,
e quindi il messaggio continua ad essere veicolato
ma il progetto emoziona, e quindi raccoglie una sensibilità
data appunto dall'attenzione dell'uso delle cose che noi già abbiamo.
Perché noi, spesso, usiamo infatti prodotti riciclati,
- tessuti, rimanenze di magazzino o scarti -
e spesso vengono abbandonati nei depositi. Noi invece li raccogliamo
(qui a Como ci sono anche delle associazioni no-profit che ci donano tantissimi tessuti,
[come] l'associazione Mare di Moda): la cosa interessante è che
tutti sono felici.
Chiaramente noi esistiamo perché
le donne detenute percepiscono un regolare stipendio
(poi vedremo un po' più a fondo questo pensiero)
e noi esistiamo se qualcuno ci conosce:
quindi, invece di fare delle borse fashion, molto belle,
poche e costose, ho scelto di fare molte borse a pochissimo prezzo,
che possono andare dai 2 ai 5 €, in modo tale da contaminare
quanto più possibile un modello di sviluppo che tocca
un nuovo stile di vita, un nuovo modo
di stare sul mercato ma anche di usare le cose che noi abbiamo.
Quindi stile di vita, filosofia, che ci ha consentito di assumere
oltre 22 detenute (abbiamo anche altre risorse esterne
che lavorano per aiutarci, appunto, nella comunicazione e nel marketing);
e con 2 euro, 5 euro alla volta siamo riusciti (adesso, per esempio,
sino a metà ottobre abbiamo fatturato oltre 400.000 €)
e questo significa che posso restituire
una gioia, una ricchezza che non è fatta più di soldi, di denaro,
ma è fatta di esperienza, di contatto con questi esseri umani,
(con) queste situazioni estremamente disagiate e solitamente inaccessibili.
La mia esperienza nel campo dell'innovazione tecnologica e sociale
mi hanno consentito proprio di lavorare su un'offerta estremamente interessante
e ho pensato quindi che la conoscenza sull'innovazione,
applicata al buon senso che è dato, appunto, da questo circolo virtuoso
dove tutti sono contenti, dove tutti vincono perché
chi dona il tessuto si libera il magazzino di tessuti bellissimi
che spesso dà sofferenza dover buttare nella spazzatura;
però se vengono donati, e riutilizzati,
sicuramente anche gli imprenditori compiono un'azione sociale.
Noi con un camper andiamo a raccoglierli, li tagliamo, li facciamo cucire
all'interno delle carceri e facciamo tantissime borse
di tutti i tipi. Adesso abbiamo fatto anche borsette per uso tecnologico,
il porta-iPad, abbiamo fatto il pigiamino
per questi prodotti di tecnologia.
Quindi, oltre alle buste della spesa, le borse per gli eventi, adesso
il package per i prodotti tecnologici.
Quindi l'innovazione, applicata al buon senso, per noi è un modello di buon uso del mondo.
Vorrei farvi vedere, e toccare con mano,
quello di cui vi ho parlato.
“Made in carcere” è praticamente la mia seconda vita:
...fanno questa cosa che devono fare così: fanno come vogliono loro!
La detenuta percepisce un regolare stipendio,
e quindi lo stipendio significa ferie, straordinari, malattia, certificato medico,
assegni familiari, ritardo, orari, l'ingresso e l'uscita, la pausa caffè,
cioè sono tutti concetti che nel reinserimento del lavoro,
nel mondo reale, sono percepiti, ma spesso una detenuta
non ha neanche mai lavorato e quindi sono concetti forti, importanti, che aiutano
proprio un meccanismo di reinserimento nel mondo reale.
A Bruxelles, la settimana europea per le piccole e medie imprese:
in apertura i vincitori del concorso per i migliori video 2010.
La corrispondente, Mariolina Sattanino.
“La crisi ci ha insegnato a guardare il mondo con occhi diversi”
ha detto il vicepresidente della commissione Tajani
dialogando con imprenditori svedesi, romeni, croati
E con due imprenditrici italiane: Luciana Delle Donne, che ha creato una cooperativa
per aiutare le detenute producendo con tessuti riciclati-
Lecce, carcere di massima sicurezza, reparto femminile.
(Ldd: "Buongiorno!") Qui nasce il marchio "Made in carcere",
creato da Luciana Delle Donne insieme a un gruppo di detenute.
(Ldd: "Vi ho portato le stoffe...") Tre anni fa, Luciana delle Donne ha lasciato la carriera di bancaria
a Milano, è tornata in Puglia ed ha avviato una cooperativa sociale.
Qui si lavora al recupero della dignità delle persone, e insieme
si recuperano anche materiali di scarto.
Tessuti che gli stilisti avrebbero buttato via vengono riciclati in oggetti di moda.
Dietro il marchio “Made in Carcere” ci sono oggi tre laboratori sartoriali
nelle carceri di Lecce e Trani, per un totale di 22 detenute,
stipendiate con il ricavato delle vendite della loro impresa,
che produce soprattutto borse per convegni e confezioni.
Se impari ad amare in un posto così brutto, e a renderlo bello,
non puoi non essere innamorata della vita, di tutto,
perché poi... fuori sembra che hai trovato il paradiso. È ovvio, no?
(Applausi)
È senz'altro un'esperienza forte, che crea un impatto
che è quello che forse oggi serve a tutti quanti.
Così, degli appunti: questo suicidio dell'economia, questo accompagnamento
alla povertà di valori, quindi il cambiamento, quello che noi stiamo vivendo,
il caos- quello è un mio schizzo che spiega il mio progetto
dove c'è sempre caos, c'è sempre ripensamento, ma dove c'è una visione
estremamente lucida, nel senso che non è possibile non fermarsi,
non generare un cambiamento che abbia in considerazione il benessere sociale diffuso:
non è possibile continuare ad arricchirsi alle spalle degli altri,
ad avere atteggiamenti di omertà, e a non ribellarsi
in situazioni di estremo disagio.
Diciamo che ci comporta – personalmente, mi comporta parecchio disagio,
e questo è un modo per esprimere che si può fare, invece,
con dei modelli di sviluppo sostenibile si può fare impresa
e quindi il mio progetto può essere replicato a livello industriale,
può avere un salto dimensionale, e su 67.000 detenuti
Il 10% è femminile, invece di 22 vorrei averne 2200 di detenute che cuciono il package, perché
la busta serve sempre a tutti.
Abbiamo avuto un'esperienza abbastanza interessante,
“Sette mostre per l'Italia”: con una barca a vela ci siamo allontanate dall'Italia
per pensare e cercare di individuare
dei modelli di innovazione sociale dove potesse esserci
una visione diversa del mondo, e dare un contributo.
Abbiamo scritto un libro, io ho scritto alcune cose
che poi, comunque, potete trovare, scaricabile, sul web,
e la cosa che più importante è lasciare un segno nel cambiamento.
Il mio indirizzo e-mail è luciana724 (luciana 7 giorni su 7, 24 h su 24)
@gmail.com (Applausi). Naturalmente
- ho solo un minuto. Naturalmente, non posso non farvi vedere
alcuni dei nostri prodotti. E quindi vi saluto offrendovi un piccolo catalogo dei nostri prodotti.
MADE IN CARCERE - Ricicliamo vite
Grazie! (Applausi)